[Musique]
donc
plus
[Musique]
je suis absolument dégoûté,
humilié
et horrifié que cela se soit produit
que
je me suis réveillé le matin du nouvel an pour voir
mon nom sur
moi pour me voir être mis aux enchères
virtuellement
avec les 100 autres
femmes musulmanes  parce que nous sommes musulmans, je suis
absolument dégoûté
[Musique]
oh [
Musique]
au moment où nous parlons, nous savons que
deux des coupables ont été l'un a
été arrêté l'autre a été
détenu l'un est un garçon de 21 ans
et l'autre est une femme et moi  Je suis
horrifié que quelqu'un nourrisse
autant de haine contre une communauté
pour qu'ils fassent ça
alors
[Musique]
moi
hey